>> Laura: IT'S TIME FOR A SEEN
AND UNSEEN SECTION, WE TURN TO
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND
ARROYO.
RAYMOND, THE PRESIDENT WAS OUT
PROMOTING HIS CANCER MOON SHOT
IN BOSTON.
WHAT IS IT?
>> IS JUST A REBRANDING OF
THINGS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
ARE YOU DOING.
CRITICS SAY THEY ADMINISTRATION
HAS REQUESTED NO NEW FUNDING FOR
THE MOON SHOT.
BUT THAT DIDN'T STOP BIDEN FROM
SELLING IT HARDER THAN ANYTHING.
>> THERE'S NOTHING, NOTHING,
NOTHING BEYOND OUR CAPACITY.
JACK, JAKE I SHOULD SAY, I WILL
USE MY 30s AS PRESIDENT TO
BREAK LONG JAMS AND SPEED
BREAKTHROUGHS.
BOSTON ZONE MONICA BERTINELLI,
EXCUSE ME.
MY WORD IS A BIDEN, THIS CANCER
MOON SHOT IS ONE OF THE REASONS
I RAN FOR PRESIDENT.
>> BLUNDERS ASIDE, THIS IS
CURIOUS GIVEN THE HISTORY OF THE
BIDEN CANCER INITIATIVE.
IT WAS FOUNDED BY JILL AND
JOE BIDEN IN 2017.
THE BIDENS BASICALLY HIRED THE
OBAMA CANCER MOON SHOT STAFF AND
PAID THEM HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY DURING THE
TWO YEARS IT WAS RUNNING.
THE BIDENS TOOK IN HER THAN
$5 MILLION IN DONATIONS AND
SPENT MORE THAN $3 MILLION IN
SALARIES AND ZEROING GRANTS.
>> Laura: WHAT?
>> ZERO ON CANCER RESEARCH.
A MOON SHOT TO NOWHERE.
>> Laura: AS A CANCER SURVIVOR
MYSELF, I FIND IT SURPRISING AND
TYPICAL FROM A FAMILY OF
GRIFTERS.
>> WOULD YOU MAKE OF THIS LAURA?
>> HAVE YOU TALKED ABOUT IT WITH
HIM?
>> NOT YET.
WE'VE BEEN TOO BUSY.
BUT I'M SURE THERE WILL BE A
DISCUSSION.
LOOK AT ALL THAT JOE HAS DONE.
HE HAS KEPT TRUE TO WHAT HE SAID
HE WOULD DO.
SO I THINK HE JUST NEEDS TO KEEP
GOING.
>> LOOK AT ALL IS DONE?
THE UNITY?
THE INFLATION?
SAFETY AND SECURITY CHRIS BURKE
I LOVE IT WHEN SHE SAYS HE NEEDS
TO KEEP GOING.
IF ONLY HE KNEW WHERE HE WAS
GOING.
HE'S TOTALLY CONFUSED, DOESN'T
KNOW WHICH WAY TO GO.
NOTE THE HANDHELD MIC HE USES
NOW LAURA TO COMPENSATE FOR HIS
DIMINISHED OF VOICE.
WHEN THE PROMPTER WENT DOWN
YESTERDAY, SO THAT THE SPEECH.
>> LOOK, THE FACT IS THAT THERE
IS A LOT WE CAN DO, A LOT WE
HAVE TO DO.
YOU KNOW, THE FACT IS THAT,
RIGHT NOW, WITH THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE LAW, AMERICA'S
REALLY GETTING ON THE MOVE
AGAIN.
>> Laura: OH, MY GOD.
IF IT WAS IN OUR COUNTRY WOULD
BE FUNNY.
>> HE'S LIKE THE PRESS
SECRETARY.
IF YOU CAN'T READ IT OR SEE IT
HE'S COMPLETELY LOST.
THIS IS HEARTBREAKING.
HOW CAN HE RUN AGAIN?
HOW CAN HE KEEP GOING?
>> Laura: BECAUSE JILL WILL
TAKE HIM TO WILMINGTON THEN DO
WHATEVER THEY DO THERE TO GET
THEM READY FOR THE NEXT WEEK.
GO AHEAD RAY.
WHAT ELSE?
YOUR MARRIOTT IN NEW ORLEANS,
LATOYA CANTRELL, SHE'S WONDERFUL
AND SHE'S FACING SOME BACKLASH
OVER HER LUXURY TRAVEL.
WHAT IS THAT?
>> THERE'S A CITY ORDINANCE HERE
THAT REQUIRES EMPLOYEES TO FLY
COACH AND TO REIMBURSE
NEW ORLEANS FOR ANY UPGRADE.
SHE WENT TO THE SOUTH OF FRANCE
THIS SUMMER AND RACKED UP MORE
THAN $30,000 IN UPGRADES SINCE
2021 AND SHE IS REFUSING TO GIVE
ANY OF THE MONEY BACK.
>> ON EXPENSES INCURRED DOING
BUSINESS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF NEW ORLEANS WILL NOT BE
REIMBURSED TO THE CITY OF
NEW ORLEANS.
ONE THING IS CLEAR: I DO MY JOB.
I'LL DO IT WITH DISTINCTION AND
INTEGRITY EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
SO THAT'S WHAT HAVE TO SAY ABOUT
THAT.
>> THIS IS WHY THERE'S A RECALL
EFFORT IN NEW ORLEANS AGAINST
MAYOR CANTRELL.
55% OF NEW ORLEANS CITIZENS
SUPPORT REMOVING THE MIRROR.
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO EXPECT A
RECALL.
>> Laura: HOW MANY OFFICERS
ARE THEY DOWN IN NEW ORLEANS?
>> ONLY ABOUT 900.
>> I JUST GLAD SHE GOT ONE OF
THOSE PO